so critical computational empowerment
that's that's one of the key concepts
that provides the Fox Harrell was one of
our guests because discuss during his
visit to class and it was a big hit in
the class because as you know we have
many engineers scientist in the course
and and many of them are so used to the
notion of of coding of computation being
supposedly neutral when it comes to
ideology and to societal tendencies but
what folks should really clearly is that
those Iraqis of power that this course
is about really are themselves embedded
in these codes in these codes that
create video games virtual reality space
platforms so if you not aware of these
hierarchies and how they are coded
really coded in those platforms then we
become prey to them without even knowing
we accept their assumptions and we
reinforce our own attitudes that might
put down women in or immigrants or
Muslims or gay people so we will become
part of this Iraqis in mentoring them
but also what Fox showed in his in his
visit is that once we understand how
coding can encode those Iraqis they may
actually create codes that will in turn
give us more flexibility for identities
that are more inclusive and more humane
towards especially women and and blacks
and Latinos and Muslims etcetera so in
one thing that that folks did in his
visit was to show us one of his
platforms where it brings them together
people at on different sides of a
conflict so one case study showed was
this conflict between the Israelis and
the Palestinians where as so this is
platform where you can bring those
soldiers together who fight on opposite
sides and through that they get to
better empathize with each other's
identities and
biographies and life circumstances so
that that was relief the powerful
concept for the students to get to
understand how coding can indeed help us
coded a better world for all